visite aujourd'hui nous terminerons par
l'un des premiers grand spectacle
musical du bicentenaire de la révolution
française à l'opéra royal du château de
versailles et bien leurs questions
nationales de radiofrance
exécuté il ya soir la marseillaise
orchestrée par hector berlioz jean-marc
bras me jean françois beck
la république en marche sous les lustres
de la royauté
bah ouais
en prélude aux fêtes du bicentenaire de
la révolution française le nouvel
orchestre philharmonique de radio france
les choeurs et la méprise interprète
outre la marseillaise orchestrée par
berlioz la symphonie numéro 1 de méhul
et les reliques de béton sous la ferme
baguette de marek janowski
j'ai pas les grands problèmes de
d'imaginer aussi en moi de produire
d'installer en moi même un certain
esprit pour français qui partagent peut
être partiellement les sentiments qui en
a comme français quand on joue un oeuvre
comme ça
un public debout pour honorer ce chant
du départ pour l'armée du rhin d'un
obscur officier en garnison à strasbourg
rouget de lisle rebaptisé marseillaise
dès sa création en 1792 grâce aux
fédérés de la cité phocéenne hymne
national trois ans plus tard cette
musique qui a des moustaches selon
appelé et mises sous le boisseau
jusqu'en 1879 haeberli aux écrits en
en-tête de sa partition pour tout ce qui
a une voix un coeur et du sang dans les
ped belle adresse à tous ceux qui
écouteront ce soir la retransmission sur
france musique dès 20h30
mais c'est sur cette marseillaise que
nous ne quitterons tout de suite après
le journal les prévisions météo avec